hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others I see there are a
whole bunch of saved up questions here
let me see uh
all right we have one here from Aaron
does gravity's strength cause a
fundamental limit for the size of a
planet what about a star what about a
whole what about the Galaxy what about
the universe good question
so
the the answer is
if you have a certain amount of mass in
a certain volume
gravity will produce some amount of
compression of what's there and for
example the uh if you have a planet
they're a pretty big exoplanets that
have been discovered around other stars
but there's a limit to the size of
exoplanet that one expects can exist I
don't know how it's some number of times
larger than Jupiter but not that many
times larger than Jupiter and anything
bigger than that will tend to turn into
a star and it will turn into a star
because what happens is that the force
of gravity will compress the material on
the planet to the point where everything
the the atoms are so squashed up against
each other that they start to undergo
nuclear fusion which is the process that
produces energy in Stars so basically
what happens is normally nuclear fusion
comes because two atoms the nuclei of
atoms get crushed together to the point
or crash into each other fast enough
that they can merge
point is nuclei protons and neutrons in
them protons are positively charged
particles neutrons and don't have any
charge electric charge and the protons
in a nucleus are such that they they
have positive charge and positive
charges repel electrostatically the
electrical forces make like charges
repel so if you have if you try and
throw two electrons at each other they
will tend to not not uh they won't hit
each other because they'll they'll
bounce off as a result of electrical
forces if you manage to get the protons
close enough if you manage to get them
to within about the distance of a proton
away from each other then the nuclear
force which holds nuclei together will
sort of take over and those protons will
will merge together and make a bigger
nucleus when that happens they release
energy that's where the energy of stars
comes from
and so
in order to get the the um uh nuclei to
to uh be able to fuse like that to
gondago nuclear fusion one strategy is
you just make them go really really fast
and if they go going fast enough that
kinetic energy can overcome the
repulsion energy associated with the
electrical forces that temperature is
millions of degrees and that's what
people who are trying to do plasma
Fusion for example are trying to do is
to replicate what happens inside the Sun
where basically the fusion is happening
because there's a high enough
temperature that the nuclei are going
fast enough that they overcome the force
of electrical repulsion and confuse
so that's one way to get nuclear fusion
is you're just going fast enough that
you overcome that electrical repulsion
barrier the other approach is to just be
crushed more and more to the point where
these these nuclei are just by by sort
of the pressure of of what's of of of uh
of the environment that they're in are
crushed together to the point where they
are close enough that they can undergo
fusion
and that's what will happen as a result
of gravity if you have a large enough
body and a small enough volume the thing
will will get crushed by gravity to the
point where eventually nuclear fusion
will start up and so if you have a
planet that's much bigger than Jupiter
maybe I I don't know how much bigger
maybe 10 times something like that
um
then
It is believed to be the case that the
sort of interior of that planet will be
crushed so much that you'll start to go
nuclear fusion I mean to give a sense of
how much crushing there is inside a
planet like Jupiter the center of
Jupiter is believed to be a solid
hydrogen solid metallic hydrogen
hydrogen is normally a gas but under
enough pressure it turns into a solid
and actually turns into a metal metallic
solid but so if you have a larger Planet
it'll sort of have larger crushing
forces and um uh will start undergoing
nuclear fusion and we'll turn into a
star
now
of course these things are complicated
because it depends a bit on what kinds
of elements are inside the planet a star
like the sun it's mostly made of
hydrogen
um which is what most of the universe is
made of but inside a planet uh the a
planet that's been formed when a star
forms the kind of heavier materials tend
to go into the sort of disk of stuff
that that is around the style that's
forming and those tend to form into
planets and things like hydrogen if the
planet isn't very big is smaller than
much smaller than Jupiter for example
like the Earth most hydrogen that is
separately a gas on the earth it all
escape the atmosphere it all the
hydrogen molecules go fast enough that
they escape the gravity of the earth and
go off into space which doesn't happen
when you have a bigger planet like
Jupiter where you still can capture
hydrogen but in any case the question of
how a sort of planet-like thing can sort
of get crushed and form a star depends
on the think or the equation of state
for the material that the star is made
of the equation of state is a fancy name
for telling one if you try and Crush
something how much pressure as you try
and reduce the volume how much pressure
will be generated and that's something
that one has to try to work out for
different kinds of materials it's very
important if you're trying to make a
nuclear explosion for example knowing
the equation of State as we crush the as
you crush things to try and make a
nuclear explosion is something it's it's
something you have to try to work out
because if you if the if the equation of
state has the wrong form so to speak
instead of you successfully crushing
things and making something which will
eventually get for example dense enough
to undergo some kind of nuclear process
the thing will just bounce and it will
be as if you you know the thing was
collapsing and then it bounced and uh
and never got crushed to to that um high
density where where those things can
happen
so
what happens uh okay so there's this
whole series of limits of you know if
you are a star of a certain size then
different things will happen to you
there's a so-called main sequence of uh
the evolution of stars over the course
of 10 billion years or whatever it was
some of them are much shorter than that
the lifetime of a star depends on the
mass of the star so for a star of the
mass of the Sun uh it's about a 10
billion year life cycle for much bigger
stars there can be a much shorter life
cycle even down to a few million years
and there are stars which kind of go
through this main sequence there's this
uh letters ob-a-f
gkm I think and the Sun is a g-type star
right now a G2 star
um and different stars go through well
depending on their Mass but um they'll
go through this the sequence of stages
and depending on the mass the end stage
of a star can end up as a white dwarf a
neutron star or a black hole and things
can happen like a big star uh can uh
undergo a violent collapse process and
make a supernova which is a huge
explosion uh the nearest Stardust
beetlejers well near star that is a
really big star really big red giant
star
um that will have a supernova as a star
called betelgeus
um which in the next few million years
will probably explode and um the uh
um
uh and that's that's some
um uh that's that's that that's it'll
make the the night sky bright on Earth
for a few days and things like that in
any case the um that there are and I
have to remember what the limiting sizes
are for these things the sun will turn
into a white dwarf eventually
um the uh uh if it's not much bigger
than the sun a star not much more
massive than the stun will turn into a
neutron star and I think it's 1.5 solar
masses is the limit at which the end
state of the star when it when it loses
the pressure that it gets from all those
nuclear reactions that are happening
when that stops sort of keeping the star
uh to be big the star will collapse and
with the amount of mass that's in the
star
um above 1.5 I think it is solar masses
um it will collapse into a black hole
now uh is there a limit on so there's a
limit there's a limit on the size of a
star
um
you know the sun is a comparatively big
star there are a lot of much smaller
stars
um that uh are kind of uh that in fact
are quite hard to detect and even quite
close to the Sun there are stars that
were only discovered comparatively
recently because they're so faint like
for example uh the closest other start
of the sun is after Centauri it's a
Triple Star
um it's about four light years away
there's another star Barnard star six
light years away
um which is a very faint star small
faint star and there are other stars
which you know don't even have names
they're just catalog numbers hip
something or other which are really
quite close to the Sun and the reason
they were not detected until fancy for
example uh spaceborne telescopes were
available it's just because they're
they're not very bright and so and
they're small and not very bright so sun
is a comparatively big star now there
are much bigger stars like for example
um is there an upper limit to the size
of a star I think there's a bunch of
discussion about that and I'm
I'm not sure what the answer to that is
my guess is that in the formation
process for a star there certainly is a
distribution of sizes and there is a
tale of larger stars that go only up to
a certain point now why can't there be a
still larger star form that I'm not sure
um I think that depends on the processes
of star formation and the way that uh
things Clump together from gravity in
the formation of stars and that there
are certainly parts of the universe
visible in telescopes which are sort of
nurseries for stars where lots of stars
are being created from dust for example
and uh
um I'm trying to remember there are all
sorts of um
uh
limits and stability criteria and things
for clouds of dust or clouds of gas
condensing into stars and perhaps from
those there is an upper limit but I I
think it's mostly that there's just a
distribution of sizes and that there's a
you know there isn't much of a tale by
the time you get up to masses you know
much much larger I don't know what the
largest ones known are maybe 20 times I
don't know
um the mass of the Sun but it's not
doesn't get hugely bigger now in terms
of of other kinds of things in terms of
black holes
um black holes when black holes can
merge a black hole once it's formed it
forms this event horizon where the
escape Velocity is larger than light the
escape velocity of the speed of light so
Things fall in but nothing gets out of
the black hole and for example there are
places in the universe where there are
binary black holes two black holes
orbiting each other they gradually lose
energy as a result of gravitational
radiation and they gradually spiral in
in the last few seconds they produce an
incredible amount of of gravitational
radiation like they like the equivalent
of converting the whole mass of the Sun
into into gravitational radiation energy
um in a matter of few seconds and then
you have a single black hole at the end
of that single spherical-ish black hole
at the end of that and that's what
gravitational wave detectors detect and
we can now pretty much detect a black
hole merger anywhere in the universe and
they happen like once a week or
something I think right now in the
universe now the most galaxies seem to
have black holes at the center of the
Galaxy which are like giant garbage
dumps for material in the galaxy and
gradually more and more things are
merging into this black holes at the
center of galaxies like our galaxy has a
black hole that has a mass of a hundred
thousand times the Sun and uh one can
expect that as galaxies get older
they'll just be more and more of the
Galaxy will be in the garbage dump so to
speak of the black hole at the center of
the Galaxy to my knowledge there isn't a
uh an immediate upper limit to the size
of that black hole certainly the
equations of standard general relativity
and the same thing will be true in our
physics project are such that you can
have a black hole of any Mass
um you can in our physics project
there'll be lower limits on mass but I
think there isn't really an upper limit
you can have a bigger and bigger and
bigger black hole and uh it's just a
black hole it's not like something like
um uh the it doesn't
um
um there's nothing for it to collapse
into it is already collapsed so to speak
so
uh now again in terms of galaxies you
know our galaxy is what 100 billion
solar masses or something maybe less
than that
um it's 100 billion stars at least uh
and um
the uh so
is there an upper limit on the size of
galaxies our galaxy is also a fairly big
Galaxy there aren't much bigger galaxies
around and I think it's like stars there
are processes that form galaxies
um mostly in the early Universe in the
case of galaxies and they come from uh
kind of regions of the universe where
it's a little bit more dense and so
things in that region will Clump into
one Galaxy things in another region will
Clump into another galaxy there's a
distribution of sizes of galaxies which
I think just has a tail I don't think
there's a there's a necessary absolute
upper limit I think it's just a question
of the clumps don't tend to get that big
um the uh
um
um
sorry
um
the um uh
so
any case the the um uh you know
so
the question was asking about is there
an upper limit on sizes of galaxies to
my knowledge there's no uh there's no
upper limit associated with can you
maintain such a Galaxy there will be an
upper limit in terms of what kinds of
galaxies were formed in the early
universe and uh that depends on things
about how galaxies were formed and
that's a complicated story it's still
not very well understood if you have uh
a I was talking about how
in the case of nuclei they tend to repel
each other because they have electric
charges that were like charges repel in
the case of gravity uh things everything
has a positive Mass there aren't so far
as we know negative Mass things dark
energy is an example of a negative Mass
thing but uh in terms of ordinary matter
it's all positive mass and all positive
masses attract so if you have a a big a
box of of stuff that all has mass and
has gravitational attraction it will it
will tend to Clump together exactly how
that comping process works is really
complicated and not well understood
the end point of that clumping process
is probably that you just form a big
black hole but uh you know the first two
Clump into one thing and then you Clump
into another thing and eventually
everything just clumps together to form
a black hole but it takes a while it
takes much longer than the current
lifetime of the universe for everything
to have just landed up in black holes
and the process of getting there is
complicated where things will kind of uh
sort of spiral around each other and
sort of the the um the sort of
rotational uh forces will cause them to
stay apart and so on it's really a
complicated story and for example the
question of exactly what happens when
you have these two things which are sort
of gravitationally attracting when they
get really close to each other what will
happen will they merge with each other
well they form a binary star system how
will it exactly work this is very
complicated and so there's less
understood about this process of sort of
self-gravitational uh self-gravitating
gases that might be but that's what's
important to understand in terms of the
formation of galaxies in the early
Universe the other thing is when there
is a slight density contrast when
there's one piece of the universe it's a
bit more dense than others the piece
that's more dense is the piece that's
going to collapse first and form a
Galaxy and that depends on the on the
sort of primordial fluctuations of
density and again that's another
complicated thing not well understood
that it's believed that in the very
early Universe there were kind of
fluctuations associated with quantum
mechanical effects and that those got
Amplified to produce the fluctuations
that eventually turn into galaxies when
it got much bigger in our model of
physics it works somewhat the same way
except that in the end there is a
discrete structure to space-time and
probably the the very early Universe
started infinite dimensional but still
with a a fairly small discrete object
and so what one might hope in sort of an
interesting possibility challenging
possibility it is that there might be a
signature in the current universe of the
actual structure of that very primordial
universe that had was consisted of a
small number of dispute elements perhaps
I mean one of the more bizarre things
that could happen in the universe is it
could be the case that there are sort of
symmetries at the very beginning of the
universe which are still manifest in the
universe today so for example one of the
absolutely bizarre things that could
happen is you know the universe could
have been had like the symmetry of an
icosahedron or something and it might be
the case that oh well we're off in some
arm of the universe over here but
there's an identical arm of the universe
somewhere else because there was a
symmetry in the very early universe
that's a possibility it doesn't seem to
be the case but that is a possibility
that is in principle out there so
in any case the um uh the formation of
galaxies and the size limits to the
galaxies are Complicated by the fact
that they depend on these primordial
density fluctuations in the universe
that are potentially left over from
quantum mechanical effects or they're
analog in our models
um as well as sort of the way in which
gases uh are pulled together by gravity
and that's a complicated set of set of
behaviors
um now the the final question asked here
was what about the universe is there a
limit on the size of the universe good
question uh our universe right now has
about 10 to the power 80 uh particles in
it protons and and so on in it
um maybe about
um a little bit more photons than that
in it it's a little bit harder to count
photons because there are some low
energy photons that sort of almost don't
count
um but so our universe has a certain
size
and could one imagine a universe that's
much bigger than our universe
I I think the answer is yes and I think
in our model of of how things work
um in the ultimate sort of
the ultimate object that represents sort
of all possible uh that represents the
sort of Ultimate Universe as this thing
we call the rouliad and the rouliad is
this kind of entangled limit of all
possible computational processes and
what we experience as our universe is a
particular slice of the rouliad that we
are kind of positioned to be
experiencing so to speak to be to be
perceiving and for example the way that
we perceive our universe and things like
counting the number of particles in our
universe well it depends what we mean by
a particle if we look down at the level
of the of the actual microscopic
structure of space which we believe to
be discrete and to have all of these
discrete elements in it maybe at a
length scale of 10 to the minus 100
meters or something like this there's a
lot of structure going on in that in in
sort of the very small scales of the
structure of space
things like particles like electrons and
photons are probably pretty big compared
to the underlying structure of space
those are the things that we who are
also pretty big compared to the
underlying structure of space I mean to
give a sense of scale the length scale
for the underlying structure of space
might be we're not sure of this estimate
but it might be 10 to the minus 100
meters the size of the universe is 10 to
the 26 meters we are about a meter tall
give or take and so we're much on the
bigger end of things in the universe
there's a lot of there's a lot of room
down below so to speak much smaller
things so when we look at the universe
and we say oh there's an electron there
there's a photon there those are pretty
big objects probably on the scale of the
actual underlying structure of the
universe and those things are
um that's
so if we were a different size for
example we might be sensitive to
features of the universe which are a
much smaller scale and so for example
counting the number of particles in the
universe right now we say oh that
electron thing that's a particle but
some little feature of space operating
down at a length scale of 10 to the
minus 80th meters or something we
wouldn't say that's a particle because
we have no awareness that that exists
it's just some little thing that's
happening which on our scale is all just
aggregated together and we don't notice
it but if we were on a very different
scale we would potentially notice it and
then our the count for the Little
Critters that are you know tiny compared
to us you know billion billion billion
times smaller than us uh that uh
experience the universe in a different
way their count of the number of
particles in the universe might be
vastly different from ours but having
said that just looking at the universe
as we perceive it as the question can we
derive the number that the Universe has
time to the 80th particles in it
interesting question is there a way of
saying well we got this universe and not
the universe that had 10 to the 10 to
the 10 particles in it or not the
universe that had you know only 100
particles in it can we derive the
approximate size of the universe it's an
interesting question and right now I
don't think we have anything to say
about that I think we don't know I think
that it is probably the case that
thinking about kind of the way that you
slice the rouliad for observers like us
there is a certain inevitability to the
size of the universe roughly within huge
margins of error but that's that's as
far as I think I can get with that I
think that the the question of uh now
now you know the question of the density
of the universe how much mass there is
per unit volume in the universe that is
something which affects things like the
universe starts off expanding but if
there's too much mass in the universe
then the gravitational effect of that
mass will cause the universe to
recontract again things like this so
there are constraints of that kind but
there's no overall scale that says the
universe should be this size and not
smaller or larger that's something will
be interesting to be able to derive from
our physics project we're not we're not
there yet
um It's actually an interesting question
whether if we know the size of the
elementary length whether we
automatically derive the size of the
universe I'm not sure good question
all right let's see
um
[Music]
right Socrates comments internal gas
pressure versus gravity are the two main
forces for Star formation from Neville I
guess indeed
um
uh
okay there's a question here from Parker
about what was the pressure of the early
Universe versus today
um
in looks at in terms of its sort of
ordinary physics terms the universe had
very high pressure it had very high
temperature very high pressure the
um uh the temperature of the universe
gradually decreases I mean in our models
of physics
it's sort of the early Universe was
really a a sort of a hotbed of activity
and it probably had infinite Dimension
infinite temperature
infinite density a lot of infinite stuff
and as the universe expands it gradually
has uh is a calmer kind of place but you
know the universe
what happened
at the level where we already have
particles formed and things like this
you know there was a time when the
universe was so small and so dense and
and our models so high dimensional that
all of the usual things we talk about
about photons and electrons so you
couldn't identify any of those things
by the time the universe is maybe I
don't know a microsecondo the nanosecond
to a microsecond old you can start to
identify definite particles of the kind
that we are used to by the time the
universe is um a second old a lot of
kind of nuclear physics type stuff is
beginning to happen and you can really
identify you know nuclei and not the
protons at least and things like that
um the uh by the time the universe is a
hundred thousand years old atoms are
forming
um and with with protons and and
electrons and neutral atoms are forming
but before that it's it's still things
are sort of too dense too hot for that
for that for it to be calm enough for
atoms to form but nuclei form uh a few
seconds after the after the beginning of
the universe you start to to form nuclei
I remember correctly let's see I could
work that out
um the temperature Falls below an Mev or
so that happens at about I think that
happens about one second and after the
beginning the
in any case the the thing that um uh and
by the way the measurement of time
is an interesting question I mean that's
time measured in sort of today's way of
measuring time
uh time in our in sort of what we
understand now from our physics project
time is sort of the progression of
computation in the universe the working
out of the next state of the Universe
from the last one that succession of
process of of making a new state from
the last that's the progress of time and
the uh so the question is in a situation
where you know wherever some sort of
infinite infinite dimensional infinite
this infinite that uh you know our our
typical clock won't work quite the same
way we can count the number of
Elementary times that have been uh in
terms of a single place in the universe
how many Elementary times how many
Elementary computational updates have
happened in the universe but if we start
saying what's the relationship of that
to other parts of the universe the usual
Notions of the time are going to get
kind of messy
um and that you know by the time one's a
nanosecond into the into the assistance
of the universe all of that stuff has
sort of worked its way out and one's
starting to be able to to talk about
well identify things like the things
that we know from our physics today and
uh and be able to understand what's
happening
um but anyway in the the the
um the pressure
of um
uh
um
pressure in the early Universe was was
very high
um
oh my we've got a we've got a um
okay all right all kinds of different
questions here all right there's one
from uh sudo
uh come on stretch a vacuum beyond the
breaking point similar to how Mata can
be compressed Beyond a breaking point
that leads to a black hole
so
um
well the vacuum is everywhere
and the vacuum doesn't have nothing in
it
the vacuum is
in our models of physics one of the most
important features of the vacuum is
maintaining the structure of space you
know it's a funny thing I discovered
that Descartes back in the early 1600s
uh had kind of a realization that is
very similar to something that emerges
from our physics project he said he
thought that the Universe was full of
little vortices that were all sort of
interacting with each other and he said
if there aren't a bunch of vortices
between two places there isn't any space
between them those places have no
distance between them and so it is in
our models of physics and in the way we
think the vacuum works there's all this
activity in the vacuum there's all of
these uh pieces of this giant Network
that represents the universe are there
and it is necessary to have all that
activity to maintain the structure of
space so there's always activity there
now
when you say well how do I disrupt what
can I do with that activity is there a
way I can sort of you know pull that
activity apart you know it's a funny
thing in um uh when people were first
understanding and this is in the 1600s
people were first understanding the idea
of a vacuum
um and uh people didn't understand the
fact that a vacuum was the lack of
molecules of a gas somewhere and they
had this funicular Theory I just learned
about this of the vacuum that involved
the vacuum is this place where there are
little little uh I mean by the way
people had a very bizarre view of how
gases worked they thought that a gas
um consisted of a bunch of uh sort of
particles that were pushed apart by
little hairs between the particles as
opposed to what happens in actually in a
gas there's just motion of the particles
and then bouncing off each other is what
keeps them on average a certain this
apart people imagine that there were
little hairs that would sort of Springs
between these these particles that would
sort of keep the gas that would produce
what was called the Spring of the air
um would would push the gas apart and so
when they came to the vacuum they
thought there was this funicular theory
in which there were little little kind
of lassus that would come from the
vacuum pulling things into the vacuum as
opposed to the vacuum is just a place
where there aren't molecules of air and
so the air is going to push out into
that vacuum
so
I think the um uh this idea of well how
can you control the vacuum well one
thing you can do is you can say I'm
going to put down these walls of of
matter in the vacuum and then what is
the property of the vacuum between those
walls versus outside those walls there
is a there is a difference it's a thing
called the Casimir effect
um between of the structure of the
vacuum between the walls now it isn't
what's different is the Quantum
processes that are going on in the
vacuum these same things which are sort
of uh versions of of the processes I'm
talking about which knit together with
the structure of space in Quantum field
Theory there's also the idea that there
are these virtual particle antiparticle
pairs formed it's I think really the
same thing as what at a very microscopic
scale I'm talking about is knitting
together the structure of space but what
happens is that the types of of so
particle antiparticle pads that can be
formed are a little different between
these two walls that you put in place
and outside them in this in this limited
region very low energy low long
wavelength particles cannot be formed
between those walls but they can be
formed outside and that leads to the
small force of attraction between for
example two metal plates just put in the
vacuum but now if you ask the question
can you sort of tear the vacuum apart
um well a couple of things to say about
that
the
okay so one very bizarre effect is a
thing called Auto ionization
so what happens is
let's see okay so when you have an
atomic nucleus it's a positively charged
then there are electrons that are sort
of floating around outside the nucleus
and according to quantum mechanics
there are certain discrete
uh possible energy levels of those
electrons it's like having it's like
imagining that you have a string and
you're sort of uh you know sort of
keeping it stationary at the two ends
and you can pluck it and it'll have a
kind of a little bow out once or twice
or three times or whatever those are
like the modes of a string and the same
thing happens with the modes of the
electron field in an atom
Okay so
in when it comes to the relativistic
theory of electrons in atoms so most
atoms most electrons and atoms are going
at a decent fraction of the speed of
light but not really close to the speed
of light
um but it turns out if you have a a
nucleus with a very high charge you will
have electrons that are in the sense
orbiting very close to the nucleus going
at a speed that is very close to the
speed of light and very bizarre things
happen
so in the in the usual just to fill in a
little bit of technical stuff here in
the usual quantum mechanics that people
will learn in college or something like
that they talk about the Schrodinger
equation which is the equation for
non-electavistic quantum mechanics when
things are going not close to the speed
of light and the the usual theory of the
hydrogen atom is based on the
Schrodinger equation there's another
thing called the Dirac equation which
governs the uh the quantum mechanics of
electrons even when they're going at
relativistic speeds close to the speed
of light
the Iraq equation was originally
developed in the 1930s by Paul Iraq
um had a very bizarre prediction it said
that in addition to there being positive
energy energy levels of electrons where
electrons have you know this energy or
double it or triple it or whatever else
there would also be negative energy
levels for electrons so that seemed very
bizarre what could that possibly be
and then what Iraq realized was that
those uh there is an anti-particle to
the electron the positron electrons have
positive I have negative charge
positrons have the flip around a
positive charge and what Dirac kind of
imagined was that you could think about
things as there's this kind of sea of
negative energy electrons and every so
often there's a hole in that sea of
negative energy electrons and that's a
positron the anti-particle of the
electron okay so the Dirac equation
talks about both electrons and positrons
and what happens is if you have a
nucleus that has that is is sort of
pulling the electrons in really close so
they're going really close to the speed
of light and so on
um eventually when the nucleus is small
enough and has a high enough charge it
will make the electrons it will
effectively uh get to the point where it
can start creating electron positron
pairs from the vacuum
so right now we have the the largest
elements the largest atomic number that
we have is what
120 or so I think it's been reached the
very short-lived elements but that's 120
protons in the nucleus okay the exciting
thing that might happen one day is when
we get to 137 uh protons in the nucleus
because at 137 protons in the nucleus
you start to get this Auto ionization
effect and what happens is it's not
completely clear that it's 137 exactly
um that's a an estimate and maybe it's a
little bit bigger than that which will
be a kind of a downer because it'll take
longer to reach but what happens is that
um the lowest energy level of the
electrons is actually pulled into that
negative energy C and so what happens
physically is that electron positron
pairs are formed and essentially what's
happening is that the electromagnetic
field associated with that nucleus is
some somehow intense enough that it can
it sort of has the energy that is needed
to produce the mass of an electron and a
positron twice the electron mass and
make those things spontaneously start
appearing so when you get so what
happens is that's essentially breakdown
of the vacuum it's um it's it's sort of
alt it's it's uh explicit polarization
of the vacuum so by the way I should say
when you put an electric field across
the vacuum you will get a phenomenon
called vacuum polarization actually
that's a there's another phenomenon that
is related to that one that is also
called backing polarization
um in Quantum field Theory but basically
what's happening is that in the vacuum
there are electron positron pairs that
are formed all the time and when you
have this strong electric field the
electron positron pair is formed and
usually those virtual particles they get
formed and they disappear in a very
short time but with a strong enough
electric field you'll be pulling one of
those particles fast enough that they
can't recombine and they don't and so
you actually get the production of
particles now what's interesting is that
that phenomenon is basically the same as
what happens in a black hole except that
in the case of a black hole the
particles are being pulled apart by
gravity in the case of an electric field
they're being pulled apart by the effect
of the electric field
and so just like in fact with black
holes and Hawking radiation and black
holes there's a similar effect with
electric Fields
um that is uh I think um Julian
schwinger was the person who pointed
this out
um the uh in the 1940s or 50s I think
um that uh a strong enough electric
field will also start spontaneously
producing particles and it it's it's all
part of the same story as the sort of
ionization story with nuclei and so on
but the end result okay so what happens
you've got this nucleus it's uh it's
producing this uh kind of it's just
spewing out electron positron pairs what
actually happens well what happens is
you've got this positively charged
nucleus and spewing out all these
particles what will happen is that the
the nucleus will get shielded by the
presence of lots of additional electrons
so actually the nucleus which started
off as a oh look there's a charge 137
nucleus or something it'll get get
shielded and eventually it's charged
it's effective charge seen from a
distance will be lower than 137 you'll
no longer get Auto analyzation and
everything will calm down but that's a
case where essentially you get breakdown
of the vacuum where where the vacuum
normally just has it sort of as in some
kind of equilibrium producing these
virtual particle pairs but when you put
an extreme enough uh sort of force on
the vacuum either an electric field or
with a gravitational field the vacuum
will break down in that sense now in
terms of of doing something where you
can like pull the vacuum apart just like
you might um have something where you
have you know a piston or something and
you're pulling a gas apart we don't know
how to do that for the vacuum
um it is uh it is conceivable okay so
normally in the vacuum there is actually
a high density of energy in the vacuum
associated with all these processes that
knit together the structure of space all
these virtual particles and so on it's
like okay there's a high density of
energy in the vacuum but so what because
it's everywhere and we don't notice it
we only notice the difference between
these kind of communal Garden vacuum and
the vacuum with some particular content
in it so so there's this there's this
zero of energy that gets reset which is
the um uh the sort of the the energy
associated with all these processors
going on in the vacuum it's a bit of
occlusion Quantum field Theory actually
the way that that's normally done it
works in a much nicer way in our in our
model physics
um it's uh the buzzword for What's Done
in in ordinary physics is um well one
piece of it is what's called normal
ordering
um but uh but that sounds very benign
but it's actually kind of a hack
um and uh
anyway the the um uh it's um
um
the the thing that um uh anyway you get
this kind of zero of energy that has
been sort of reset by our well it's it's
that vacuum is happening everywhere so
we can count that as a zero of energy
okay so there is
a phenomenon that may or may not be real
uh the phenomenon of dark energy and
dark energy is a um uh
um
is the thing where
um uh it's something that is is
effectively negative Mass matter uh and
it is something which if it exists can
be account can account for the more
rapid acceleration that appears to be
seen in the expansion of the universe
because when you have positive Mass
matter it attracts and it's all pulled
together but if you have negative Mass
matter you get anti-gravity and things
are pushed apart
um now what that corresponds to in terms
of our models of physics and things like
that is dark energy corresponds to
places where there is in a sense less
energy in the universe and where there
is in a sense less activity less things
knitting together the structure of space
But nevertheless as much space as there
was before so that's the tricky part
that normally the sort of the amount of
activity determines the amount of space
but this is a place where the I mean
it's a more complicated thing because
the amount of activity determines the
energy density the actual amount of
spaces to turn common by what that
activity actually Nets and so so that's
how you get the sort of mismatch that
can lead to things like dark energy so
that's the sort of closest to you know
you pull the vacuum apart and what's
left over when the you know when the
ocean Parts is something which which has
less energy that corresponds to dark
energy
let's see
um
okay so William comments on um
uh Quantum field there in general
relativity the zero point of energy
seems to be arbitrary uh well it's not
arbitrary in general relativity in the
theory of gravity the zero of energy is
is associated with the cosmological
constant
uh which is a thing that you just sort
of put in there in the equations and it
will determine the overall expansion
rate of the universe the point is that
that energy you can say well we're doing
everything relative to the zero of
energy and that works up until the point
where you say well let's look at it for
the whole universe how much you know
what's what's the in terms of things
happening in the universe yes you can
you can reset the zero manager however
you want but in terms of looking at the
cosmology of the whole universe you
cannot
um
let's see
and William also asks
Why is flat space
the lowest possible energy state
[Music]
um
that's an interesting question
um
flat space is um
okay
so what we consider to be flat space is
a somewhere where there is no
gravitational field that we can tell
and okay this is this is about to get
complicated because the
um
I think
I mean I could give some very technical
Arguments for why flat spaces the
mineral energy configuration but I'm not
sure it's actually true and I'm not sure
we know it's true and for example uh you
know one of the things that can go wrong
with the universe is that it's unstable
that the configuration of the universe
that we're in right now is just
teetering on the brink it's like it's
like you're boiling a pot of water and
you manage to get it above 100 degrees
Centigrade but there are no bubbles
forming yet because the the the thing
you're boiling it in is so smooth that
there's no nucleation of Bubbles and it
is hotter than 100 degrees Centigrade
but it isn't to the point where bubbles
of gas are forming because bubbles of
gas forming creates you have a
homogeneous fluid where everything's the
same when you form a bubble of gas it's
an inhomogeneity and you can you can you
know super heat the fluid to some extent
without the formation of bubbles of gas
super cool it below for reason point and
you'll get a certain amount of of uh
you'll be able to go if if you don't
have any nucleation Center if you don't
have any little little piece of dust or
something on which there's an
homogeneity that starts that starts to
form an Ice Crystal then you can
potentially you know super cool it
superheat it and so on so one of the
possibilities is we're living in sort of
a superheated universe and if something
happens in it it'll be unstable and
suddenly it'll boil
and so for example one of the things I
figured out years and years ago in the
late 1970s is um uh in the standard
model of physics the standard model of
particle physics
the it's a sort of a hacky story but
particles get their masses by
interacting with this thing called the
Higgs field which is a thing that is
believed to exist throughout the
Universe and basically particles get
massed by the fact that as they move
they're continually interacting with
this Higgs field and that's sort of
continually giving them that process of
interaction sort of slowing down those
particles and giving them a mass and the
amount of mass of a particle is just
supposed to be proportional to the
extent to which it interacts with this
Higgs field
okay so it turns out that there are
effects to do with virtual particles
that
um affect the density of this Higgs
field in the universe
and in particular if there are particles
that interact very strongly with the
Higgs field so that they have very high
mass
then uh virtual particle uh particle
antiparticle Loops of those things being
produced
have an effect on the Higgs field and if
those particles interact strongly over
the Higgs field they can have a big
effect on the Higgs field okay bottom
line story
um if you have a quark with a mass of
above maybe around 200 times the mass of
the proton you have the possibility to
make the universe unstable so when the
top Court was discovered Mass what 175
times the mass of the proton roughly
that that was it's kind of squeaking in
to um uh
uh to the region that that I figured out
ages ago leads to instability of this
whole sort of uh House of Cards
that exists in the standard model of
physics with Higgs fields and things and
so what would happen so so if in fact
there is an instability what that means
is the current structure of the universe
with all the masses of particles the the
vacuum expectation value the level of
Higgs field that exists in the universe
all of that stuff will be a meta stable
State something like a super heated
liquid and if there is a nucleation
front the the then the universe would
just completely change its character
there'd be sort of a bubble formed in
the universe which would get bigger and
bigger at the speed of light and as soon
as it hits some region of the universe
oops you know electrons don't don't have
a mass anymore and this happens and that
happens and the whole physics of the
universe changes uh you know as a as a
um as uh some as an entity living in the
universe you won't know what hit you
because the front of the meta stability
front moves at the speed of light so you
don't get to say oh my gosh it's coming
you know freak out type thing because
it's coming at the speed of light and no
signal can get to it faster than it gets
to it just itself
so it's kind of a a um uh actually it's
sort of an interesting analog to um the
phenomenon I I should think about this
the interesting analog to the phenomenon
of computational irreducibility the fact
that you sort of can't know what's going
to happen faster than uh than it gets to
you if that if something is going at a
bit of light
so
uh
yeah so it's a few thoughts on that and
I you know the
I don't think it's totally obvious that
flat space is the minimum energy stable
configuration
um I think that's a thing people have
tried to derive it
in um
even in discrete models uh things like
spin Network models and things
in our models
in our models
um
I think we know
it's a good question I I'm not
completely sure how
um I think it's inevitable yeah I think
by the time I think our derivation of
general relativity also guarantees that
flat space is the
is the mineral energy configuration
um
well at least minimum energy
configuration within configurations that
aren't too weird
and
you know in our models of physics there
can be things much more exotic than
black holes that exist in the structure
of space-time and they're not yet well
cataloged and that's an important thing
to to get done
let's see
the question here from Satoshi
uh asking about any ideas about hacking
nature to gain powers like infinite
energy travel faster than light do you
think they're possible can we really
hack the laws of nature
so the thing to realize is that sort of
engineering and Technology it's all kind
of hacking one's way into making use of
the laws of nature to do things
and I think it's more a question of what
one wants to do than what's out there to
do things with because one of the things
is like once you have a universal
computer once you have something capable
of being Universal computer you can in
principle do any computation with it
and so you might say well you know
that's the end of hacking but it isn't
because there's a there's a sort of
practical issue of well what computation
do you want to do and how do you
actually get to do it and so on and I
think one of the things that we we
discover about the universe and and
things in it and so on is that we're
continually realizing that we can sort
of access and make use of for something
we care about more and more features of
of the Universe I mean there was a time
when you know electromagnetic radiation
has been around since the beginning of
the universe but we only discovered how
to make it into radio near the end of
the 19th century
and uh so that's sort of a hack to the
universe is let's use electromagnetic
radiation to send signals let's use this
or that effect to do something that's
useful to us
now there are things where we've said oh
that's just impossible and there's a
question of of uh uh you know how we can
get around that I mean my guess is that
things like I don't know energy use for
example
um it's uh you know in in um
it seems worth important to us today
given that we're still you know physical
beings running around driving our cars
flying out planes things like this if we
were you know a box of disembodied Souls
sort of implemented in a digital format
I don't think we care as much about
energy use because we wouldn't need uh
you know we wouldn't probably need as
much energy and by the way by the time
everybody's inside that some you know
that virtualized world the notion of how
fast time goes and oh we got to run the
thing at a high clock speed and use lots
of energy to do that well it doesn't
really matter because whatever's going
to happen assuming assuming that uh you
get to hang out there for the rest of
Eternity so to speak
um you you know the the what you're
going to care about in your experience
is how time passes for you relative to
other things that you are in your domain
of experience and there's no absolute
notion that but in a case I think there
are things where you know the amount we
care about it is going to depend on sort
of what condition we're in so to speak
and I I do think that in terms of things
like energy I I would suspect that there
will be hacks in quotes whether it's you
know uh
sort of tapping into the geothermal
energy that's um uh that the Earth has
had for the last four billion years and
you know making use of the immense
amount of heat that is inside the Earth
or whether it's figuring out how to
slide one's way into being able to do
nuclear fusion or or one of a variety of
other kinds of techniques you know I
think it is quite possible that there
will be a hack and quotes where one can
just say up solve the energy problem
um that that uh seems likely to me
actually
um how long it will take and exactly
what form it will be I don't know I mean
the fact that we can get energy by you
know burning oil that comes that was
sort of created in the Carboniferous
period you know a few hundred million
years ago and so on by a bunch of trees
coming onto the land and becoming
fossilized the fact that that works is
itself an amazing hack
um I think that there are things that
sort of seem like impossibilities like
traveling faster than light one of the
things I realized is that in our model
of physics
the problem of traveling faster than
light is really it's more of an
engineering problem because what does it
mean to travel faster than light it
means in the structure of space as space
is normally perceived you can't go in in
a certain region defined by the
structure of space you can't Traverse
that region faster than the speed of
light but it's the tricky thing because
sort of space is a dynamic structure and
so you can imagine that there are places
where sort of there are pieces of what
form space which if you could pick the
exact right one at the exact right time
you could kind of surf your way through
and go faster than light it the analogy
is this you think about a bunch of gas
molecules in a room most gas molecules
only go a millionth from a meter before
they hit another gas molecule and their
direction is randomized and if you say
how long does it take for a gas molecule
to go from one side of the room to the
other takes a pretty long time one could
tell that by you know how fast does a
smell travel through the air so to speak
it's pretty slow so that's because gas
molecules aren't even though each
individual sort of uh run of a gas
molecule the gas molecule is going
basically at the speed of sound
um it keeps on hitting other gas
molecules and so it it has this random
walk that an aggregate goes very slowly
but if you could pick the exact right
collisions to have and if you kind of
navigate your gas molecule you could
have it go at the speed of sound across
the room and so it is I think with going
at the speed of light if you could kind
of navigate your way to picking which
parts of the structure of space you
attach yourself to you can probably surf
your way faster than light
but the problem is sort of what's
happening is that great big Photon
that's making the light has to just go
according to the average structure of
space and what you'd be doing is hacking
your way to something tiny compared to
the photon that's sort of hacking its
way through the microstructure of space
and uh the difficulty with that is well
that's all well and good but what can
you actually put through the
microstructure of space you probably you
yourself this great big thing that's
made of you know 10 to the 100 you know
atoms of space or something you're not
going to fit through that microstructure
of space you might be able to send a
signal maybe if you could find a way to
sort of detect create that
microstructure perturbation and detect
it at the other end but you know if it's
like well I'm gonna get on the faster
than light spaceship and go and hop to
the other side of the universe or
something it's not going to be you that
does that because you don't fit probably
you would be shredded uh into little
your sort of micro pieces of space in
order to sort of fit through the tunnel
that corresponds to the thing going
faster than light that that's my guess
about how that will work
but um there's a
you know there are things that are
uh sort of
in a sense logical and mathematical
computational impossibilities that we
won't be able to get around so for
example computational irreducibility the
fact that there are computations where
to know the answer you just have to do
the computation we don't get to get
around that if we did get around that I
know should we just get around it by
saying well we're changing our notion of
time because time is this inexorable
process of sort of computing the next
state of the universe and if the next
state of the universe can be computed
more easily in effect that means there's
less time that's elapsed so so this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that is a sort of hard
limit but it is determined by it sort of
maps itself on to our perception of time
so I think there are there are things
where it's like we're not going to be
able to get around it but by redefining
ourselves like redefining you know how
the passage of time works or or in the
case of traveling faster than light sort
of redefining what counts as us and so
on yes we'll be able to get around what
are in a sense hard constraints on the
structure of the universe but the when I
say we'll be able to get around it it's
not really the it's not really we that
gets to do it because it is an observer
an entity very different from us that
gets to be able to do those kinds of
things the US can't sort of fit
ourselves into into the structure of of
physics in a way that lets the us as we
are currently constituted be able to do
those kinds of things
well let's see maybe one more
question
um
turbulent is commenting you can travel
fast in the light of the space between
you and your destination changes
um happens if the universe expands
and that's why we get measurements
faster than the speed of light and space
well
uh yeah this is a complicated mess
um
there are all kinds of funky things that
happen you know
the speed of light is how much distance
do you Traverse in a certain amount of
time
and time I'm saying is defined by this
sort of progress computational progress
of the universe distance is defined in
our models by this sort of hypograph of
atoms of space knitted together and that
hypograph is maintained by activity that
happens through time and this question
of sort of what's the amount of space
that the activity can Traverse
uh in a certain time it's a pretty
detailed question
and
even in standard general relativity
standard theory of gravity
ah there are complicated things I mean
it's some they're a complicated
complicated definitional issues
um about
uh
what's a thing that an actual Observer
could really detect as traveling faster
than like let me give an example
foreign let's say you have a flashlight
and you're you know it's it's it's a
flashlight it's let's say it's a laser
it's powerful enough that you can paint
it on the moon that you can you know
shine it from Earth and there'll be a
spot on the moon okay you move that
laser just a tiny bit on the earth the
spot will move really fast on the moon
it might even move faster than the speed
of light on the moon
but it's a cold complicated issue when
you when you move the light there's and
and it's going to get to a different
part of the Moon how does it uh you know
exactly who gets to see it when and what
Observer who is in this position gets to
observe this and that and the other
thing and it gets pretty tricky and
there are a lot of sort of almost
paradoxes like the flashlight at a great
distance and by the way we see uh events
uh you know in in telescopes see
astrophysical events astrophysical
phenomena where it looks like there's a
jet that's moving fast in the speed of
light but in fact that's
um uh that's for this phenomenon for the
reason of this kind of the flashlight is
shining a very long distance and you're
seeing kind of the effect of the
flashlight but it's not that there is
material communication from the first
position of the flashlight to the final
position of the flashlight those are
separate photons so to speak that went
to the first position of the flat
flashlight and the last position of the
flashlight it is our perception that
there is a connection between the first
position and the last position but
there's nothing that actually goes from
that first position to the last position
so there are a bunch of effects in
general relativity in the standard
theory of gravity that work that way
um and there there are all sorts of you
know warp bubble effects and all kinds
of things like this that are essentially
working by distorting the structure of
space in that particular case in a way
that makes it so that
an observer and where it's a tricky
thing to assess what's the Observer
what's the feature of the Observer
versus what's the thing itself and
what's intrinsic and what's not and
that's something that one it's a very
subtle phenomenon I mean for example
with black holes it took 50 years from
the time when the basic sort of
gravitational uh
phenomenon that led to black holes the
schwartshot solution to the Einstein
equations was discovered in 1916 but it
wasn't known until solidly into the
1950s or even 1960s what black holes
were physically like and it wasn't known
for example that as you pass over the
Event Horizon of a black hole that you
wouldn't suddenly you know that
everything wouldn't uh you know if
you're in a spacecraft and it goes
through the Event Horizon
you actually don't notice that the event
horizon is merely a mathematical thing
the only thing you notice is that if you
uh that you won't get uh that if you
send a signal out
that signal you'll never get a
conversation happening with anybody
outside the black hole your signal will
take in a sense an infinite time to
reach somebody outside the black hole
and even though they could preemptively
be sending you hey here's the next
episode of that TV show they can be
beaming it to you and that can reach you
if you say hey I want to stop watching
that TV show I want to watch another one
that message will never get to them if
you're inside the event horizon or black
hole but that wasn't known that that was
that that at the Event Horizon your
spaceship wouldn't be pulled apart and
all kinds of other different bizarre
phenomena it wasn't known that that was
a mere mathematical coordinate
Singularity until well 1940s it was sort
of known but it wasn't really
internalized until the 1960s and so it's
often very tricky to figure out you know
what's a a genuine effect that an
observer okay here's another tricky
thing you could have a theoretical
Observer who will notice some effect but
that Observer isn't like us so to speak
and so it's kind of like well that
Observer which is the size of an atom
would notice this but for an observer
like us we're not going to notice that
and uh so it's it's a really tricky
thing to figure out
um in what you know the underlying
Theory versus what we observe about
um uh about it
um
so let's see a couple of comments here
and then should probably wrap up soon
um
okay
uh William is commenting you can't
distinguish the geometry of empty space
from one that has matter uniformly
distributed in it yes that is true
ah this is again another
sort of can of worms about what can You
observe versus not observe
I mean
you know if you have a spacecraft and
it's going through that
that region of space and there are
hydrogen atoms there and your spacecraft
is going at 99.99 of the speed of light
and it keeps on getting hit by well
hydrogen atoms aren't so bad but it
keeps on getting hit by matter
um
then
uh you know it's still going to notice
that it isn't just flat space
now you know one of the tricky things
about oh uniform distribution of matter
is like uh not having any matter there
at all
yeah I mean because
there are things like particles
there isn't really a way to get a purely
uniform distribution of matter now
having said that things like the Higgs
field are taken to be a purely uniform
distribution of matter although that's a
hack and it's really more of a
mathematical construction than it is
perhaps something real but yes the um
yeah it was spare parts is commenting
it's like you need to solve the puzzle
of constructing the space you want to
travel through before you can travel
through it yes that's absolutely right
if you could figure out oh I mean it's
kind of like
let's give an example let's say you've
got a plane and it's flying through
you know it's flying through the air and
it wants to avoid that piece of
turbulence
it it could be the case I mean it might
detect it with weather radar or
something like this and just fly around
it right now but that's in a sense this
is kind of like uh to really be able to
do that the plane would have to make a
plan at the beginning that says I can
compute the turbulence in the atmosphere
and I'm going to make a plan to fly from
New York to Los Angeles or something I'm
going to pick this particular route
which I can compute will not encounter
any turbulence now we can do that to
some extent with weather forecasting and
so on on a large scale but you can
imagine doing it on the smallest
possible scale and saying yes I can
compute my path and then it's going to
happen this way and so similarly in the
case of the structure of space you could
say well I'm going to compute my path
and uh and be able to sort of surf my
way through the structure of space
um I mean it reminds me a little bit of
um uh
there are situations like submarines for
example where it's like well you can go
through water or you can boil the water
in which case you're not going through
water you're going through gas
um and there are effects like that or or
you can be producing you can be uh
putting out some kind of um uh polymer
that makes the the um the friction
between the skin of the submarine and
the water go down because it's kind of
like a a coating of the submarine where
where you get these molecules that go
out into the water and cause the water
to slide more easily over the over the
submarine and again it's kind of like
you can you know you're sort of building
the environment that you're trying to
travel through and yes that's ultimately
what you would have to do to be able to
to sort of hack the structure of space
to go faster than light is you'd have to
be able to know what is going to be at
the next moment in time what's going to
change in the structure of space or I
could bet on that on going in that
direction rather than in that direction
and then I'll be able to make the bridge
to this other it will go like this Etc
et cetera et cetera now realistically
computational irreducibility completely
bites you but it isn't absolutely
certain well okay it probably completely
bites you but it could be the case that
just like there are particles like
electrons and so on there might be
little space tunnels that get formed
that form and disappear form and
disappear but if you could just find
those space tunnels they might be at a
very microscopic scale and say I'm going
to go down this piece is based tunnel
this piece is based tunnel and so on
then you might be able to uh
um
kind of uh surf your way through the
structure of space
all right we've had a very um
uh
oh boy
all right one more physical question and
I really should go
um and another time we'll talk about
some of the non-physics questions Aggie
is asking why is the refractive index
for x-rays smaller than one
uh
don't know for sure that it is but I'm
guessing that that is
okay refractive index tells you
when a when light goes into a material
okay when light is going through a
vacuum
the usual picture is that there's an
electromagnetic wave and it's just
exists in the vacuum and it doesn't
require an ether it doesn't require
something like you know like sound it's
compression and rare fraction waves in
air light
and electromagnetic radiation doesn't
seem to require something like that it
can just be its own thing in a vacuum
actually in our models of physics it
doesn't quite work that way and it does
in a sense it is in a sense a feature of
the structure of space so it's going
back to a theory which existed in the in
the 19th century really of kind of that
there will be an ether that supports
electromagnetic waves that theory went
into distribute because the single The
Ether drift was not observed in the
Michaelson Molly experiment in 1900 and
that was one of the stimulations for the
for the special relativity in 1905 but
the fact is that that in our models by
uh in a very very natural way we
sidestep the non-relativistic the
relativity breaking aspect of the ether
um and we have something which is kind
of like the structure that makes up the
universe that does satisfy relativistic
invariance so uh it's one of those
things where in a sense the model was
rejected too early because people didn't
see around kind of the structure of the
model enough to be able to see that it
was possible to take something like that
it's not at all in detail like like the
the model from the 19th century but but
um the the concept that there would be a
thing through which electromagnetic
waves uh travel like sound waves travel
through the air but any case the um
uh electromagnetic waves light waves
x-rays all those kinds of things in a
vacuum they just do their thing when
they encounter Mata what happens is one
atom will absorb the photon of light and
then we'll re-emet it
and so when you shine a beam of light on
a material even a transparent material
but well transparent material what's
happening is the the at the photons of
light are being absorbed by the atoms at
the surface then they are being
re-emitted and then they're being
absorbed by the atoms one layer in and
it keeps going it keeps on sort of
passing the atom passing the photon from
one atom to another in the case of
something like a metal you're stopped at
the beginning the atom is absorbed and
the the photon is absorbed and no no new
photon is re-emitted but in the case of
a transparent material there are photons
re-emitted the thing is there's a time
delay before the re-emission happens and
that time delay causes light to travel
more slowly in that Medium like in glass
it travels one and a half times more
slowly than a vacuum in water 1.33 times
more slowly and so on and that's
happening because the when it when the
photon is absorbed into the atom it
takes a little while the photon
absorption causes an electron in the
atom to go into a higher energy State
and it will it will then go down as the
lower energy state but that whole
process takes a little amount of time
and so that's what determines in a sense
the refractive index of the material
um that that time delay okay so now
hump what happens is
um
it's a little tricky because
the
am I going to be able to explain this
I'll just say the sort of technical way
it works first
if you ask
the question if okay let's say you have
a beam of light
and that beam of light is a piece of
electromagnetic radiation
and the ultra magnetic radiation is a
wave that has a certain frequency so
what's happening is you know at this
moment in time
um the electric field is in this
direction a billionth of a second later
the electric field is 90 degrees away
and the magnetic field is in that first
Direction that's kind of how much that
wave works just like a water wave at
this moment in time the water is up at a
next moment in time it's down and that's
when it wave the electric field is in a
certain direction the magnetic fields in
certain direction and so on and that's
that's how you make an electromagnetic
wave
now what's what's happening then is you
sh you make an electromagnetic wave you
you you know you shine it on a material
so to speak and what's happening is in a
standalone magnetic wave there'll always
be another wave front it's just like
like there's the wave goes up goes down
goes up goes down light should feel
magnetic field whatever just keeps going
and it's a it's a kind of continual
train of of waves so to speak and so and
then you can ask the question when that
train of waves goes into the material
uh what happens to the the phase of
those waves so in other words is it the
case that those waves are
um
you're you're making it so that when you
know you you've got these waves you
might see them on the surface of water
for example and then the water goes into
a different region let's say that's a
shallower piece of the of the harbor or
something like that and the water waves
might will change that can change their
character but they might they'll have
the same frequency potentially they'll
still be being driven at the same rate
but the distance between the wave fronts
might change and the um uh and that's
and that that um that distance between
the wave fronts will affect the um
uh
that affects
that's like determining the some kind of
effective speed for the wave
so in the I mean to be mathy about it uh
there's a thing called the phase
velocity which is Omega over K
Omega is the frequency K is the
so-called wave number which is the
inverse of the wavelength and Omega over
K has the dimensions of a speed and it
is if you count the the the frequency of
the wave how often it's wiggling up and
down and you look at the distance
between wave fronts but um then that
gives you one measure of this quote
speed of the wave
but it's it's a it's a measurement that
is something that uh you know once the
wave is sort of you have an infinite
train of waves that's you're you're sort
of measuring uh how that works
there's a different measure of kind of
speed of waves it's called the group
velocity mathematically it's domega
Decay
um the the derivative of the it's the
slope of the Omega k
um
curve
and that basically tells you if you have
a packet of waves that might be you know
if if you were a a bit of information a
fiber optic cable it might be there's a
one bit that's there and then there's
another one that's a zero bit that's
there it's a it's a big a kind of clump
of waves it's not a continuous sequence
of wavefront wavefront wavefront forever
it's a clump of waves together and it's
like there's no waves at all and then
you have this Clump and that represents
a one you know it transfers information
so the the usual kind of calculation of
sort of what happens is uh and and sort
of transmitting information is to do
with group velocity and the group
velocity is never bigger than the speed
of light in anything we've ever seen in
the universe the phase velocity is kind
of a mathematical trick
can end up being larger than the speed
of light which means uh the refractive
index can be less than one and and
that's um uh
um it's some
um uh that that's that that's that's how
that works so I think I think I don't
know it for I should know this but I
don't know it um I think what's
happening is the phase velocity is is
larger than the velocity of light but
it's just a mathematical trick it's not
something that is actually capable of um
uh of transferring information so to
speak
um it's uh so anyway I better go
um get back to my day job here
um but thank you for a lot of
interesting questions and uh
I see a lot saved up for another time I
think there are a lot of
uh some about biology and some about
technology and
um uh this is always fun for me I'm uh
um
the the terrible thing is that even
subjects that I think I know pretty well
I realize as I try and explain it to you
all that um uh there are little rough
edges and I I try and smooth them as I
explain these things and those help me a
lot in understanding things better and
uh let's say well I really appreciate
the questions that simulate that okay
off for now uh thanks very much bye see
you another time